john baker the director found you on
instagram and now you're the star of a
heartbreaking
tragic hilarious film some think acting
in hollywood should be left to the pros
but little do they know just how many
amazing performances have come from
total non-actors
that's right whether it was their first
role ever or they lucked into the part
there have been some absolutely
incredible acting jobs that have been
done by people who never
even thought of themselves as actors in
the first place from henry golding to
dave bautista
these awesome first timers absolutely
blew our minds
at first i said no and then he said it
was a thousand pounds a day
when dave batista appeared on screen as
drax in guardians of the galaxy
he was so good that we never knew that
he wasn't really an
actor dave started out as a wrestler
mixed martial artist
and bodybuilder before he made his big
wrestling for wwe
i know something you don't know but even
though he had a thriving career
he wanted to be an actor more than
anything so he quit wrestling and
actually went broke for three years
before
landing the role of drax surprising
everyone with his hilarity and
impressive improv skills
and i said that i will never go back to
wrestling until i
prove what i set out to prove and that
was that i could make it as an actor
it's not uncommon for gorgeous people to
make the jump from modeling to acting
i mean just look at cara delevingne and
mila yovovich but few have so completely
become their
characters quite like hunter schaefer
and her heartbreakingly beautiful
performance as jewels in euphoria
should i be concerned schaefer started
out walking important runways like dior
and marc jacobs before auditioning for
jules
but that's hardly all she did hunter is
also a visual artist
and lgbtq rights activist who once sued
north carolina over a discriminatory
bathroom bill
i have no idea what you're talking about
when you're as famous and universally
beloved as singer songwriter lenny
kravitz
it's no surprise that you're gonna get a
ton of offers
and as it turns out lenny actually spent
20 years fending off
offers to act in movies before he
decided to make an appearance as cinna
in the hunger games
and he only did so after meeting the
director and reading the first novel
because he told himself that he would
never be in a movie just
because read the book and
fell in love with the book couldn't put
it down
while these days we can't imagine a
world without jennifer lawrence the
movie star
if she hadn't clawed her way tooth and
nail into the 2010 indie drama winter's
bone
we might never have known her at all
before winter's bone
lawrence was working as a model and when
she auditioned for the movie the
director actually thought she was too
pretty for the part
so jayla flew all night to where they
were holding the auditions and went
in without showering apparently it
worked because she got the part
and the rest is history some could say i
was too attractive
for the part i didn't look right when
you start out as famous as harry styles
did
in the boy band sensation one direction
it can be hard
to shake the reputation as no more than
a teenage heartthrob
so when harry was cast as alex the world
war ii
soldier in christopher nolan's dunkirk
audiences everywhere were totally
skeptical that he could pull it off
all that changed when we saw the movie
and realized just how talented stiles is
on stage and off when i kind of heard
about this movie it was something that
i feel like i would have been really
excited to watch had i not been
involved at all if you thought henry
golding looked familiar the first time
you watch
crazy rich asians you might be totally
surprised to find out that it
isn't because he already had a
flourishing acting career
golding had never acted before he was
cast as the dashing nick
not that you'd ever guessed that by his
amazing performance
instead golding had been the host of a
travel show on the bbc
it wasn't until an accountant working on
crazyrich asians saw him on tv
and suggested him to the director that
he was brought in to audition
and yes my family has money but i've
always thought of it as theirs
not mine sometimes directors have to go
outside of the normal hollywood casting
offices in order to find the right
actors for their movies
and we mean way outside take bria
vinaithy
the incredible actress who rose to fame
playing a protective yet troubled mother
in the florida project
before the movie bria never even
considered being an actor
she was minding her own business selling
um
hemp themed clothing over instagram when
the director contacted her via dm
and it said hey i emailed you about a
film opportunity
she took three weeks of acting classes
and the next thing she knew she was on
the hollywood a-list
can you give me advice about what do i
need to do on instagram
to get like spotted long before she
ended up a celebrity herself
jamila jamil had made a career out of
interviewing other celebrities
that's right before she even considered
becoming an actress jamil was actually a
tv host and
interviewer in london on bbc radio 1. so
even though she had plenty of experience
on camera when she stepped onto the set
of the good place
she had never actually acted before i
never wanted to be on television i'd
never
done anything i had no experience even
though most of what goes on in grey's
anatomy
isn't based in real life one aspect of
it is very authentic and that is the
beloved scrub nurse
nurse bowkey kathy c who plays nurse
bowkey
is a real life scrub nurse when the
cameras aren't rolling
and still works in medicine in los
angeles
before the open casting call went out
for the somali pirate rolls in captain
phillips
barcode abdi sold mobile phones at his
brother's shop at a mall in minneapolis
and worked as a limousine driver and as
a dj
all of that changed when he was cast in
the role that would earn him an oscar
nomination
working opposite tom hanks it turns out
he was only paid 65 000 for the role
even though captain phillips grossed
over 200 million worldwide
and went back to working with his
brother after but don't worry he has
since developed a thriving acting career
look at me sure i'm the captain now in
angelina jolie's feature directorial
debut unbroken
she wanted to tell the incredible story
of louis vampirini
an olympic runner turned war hero turned
prisoner of war
in order to do so she had to cast an
amazing actor to play the terrifying
antagonist
sergeant mutsuhiro watanabe aka the bird
instead of hiring a friend from
hollywood angelina instead
chose to cast miyavi a very famous
japanese music producer and
singer-songwriter who had never acted
before
to take on the task of bringing the
sadistic sergeant to life
that's why i wanted to try to put
humanity
into the character in 2018
alfonso quran's roma captured the hearts
of moviegoers everywhere
in large part due to the amazingly
understated performance
by eliza aparicio as cleo yelitsa was
actually a preschool teacher before she
was plucked from obscurity and chosen to
star in roma
she was nominated for an oscar for her
part in the film and nowadays continues
to act in mexico
as well as working as an advocate for
the rights of indigenous peoples and
domestic workers in mexico
while mariah carey had actually made her
acting debut in 2001's glitter
we're pretty sure she'd rather we all
forget that and focus on her amazing
work
as miss weiss impressions which we
consider her real acting debut
the part was a complete 180 especially
for a mega star who doesn't usually like
to be seen by the public
unless she's professionally lit and in
full makeup
oh there was makeup it just wasn't meant
to look good right totally
non-glam when barbie ferreira was cast
as the ambitious cat in euphoria
she had absolutely no acting experience
under her belt
instead she'd been focused on modeling
ever since she was a teenager
which might come as a total surprise
when you watch the show she's clearly
gorgeous but an amazing actor right out
of the gate
it was very much based off you know me
as a teen when we think about the fact
that jennifer hudson not only didn't win
american idol but she came in seventh we
can barely believe it
and yet her story is one of the best out
there because not even two years after
she left the show
she made her acting debut as effie in
dream girls
and won her first academy award take
that simon and paula
now that we know that all of these
amazing performances were done by people
who had never acted before
we feel like we can go out and win
ourselves an oscar too or
maybe we should give surgery a try like
kathy c
what do you think thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time